the most popular magic tricks of science
typically have to do with magnetism
the performer floats something heavy in
the air
without anything touching it
and the gullible crowds go
[Music]
one famous trick has a ball being
levitated with magnets
ordinary folk watch and conclude that
magnetism is absolute magic
it seemingly works by remote control
action at a distance they call it
but is it
is this really magical action at a
distance
what if we could make the invisible
mediators that mother nature uses to do
this trick visible
if we could see that the magnetic field
holding the ball up consists of
countless threads swinging under it
the trick would no longer be so mystical
and incomprehensible
here's another stunning scientific magic
trick that wows the crowds
the earth goes around the sun
and there's nothing between our planet
and our star to justify such behavior
action at a distance
remote control
attraction without a mediator as
immanuel kant described it
of course if we could make visible the
invisible entities father universe uses
to do this magic trick
it wouldn't be so mysterious now would
it
the only reason people marvel at such
tricks is that they can't see the
mediators
laymen reply with what seems obvious to
them
that there's nothing there
they can't see or touch the alleged
mediators
the fault lies with the crowds
misconceived definition of object
people casually invoke the irrational
definition found in all dictionaries and
used throughout the world
object
that which we can touch or see
this definition is irrational because
not all objects can be seen or touched
c and touch require a second object
and this is an experiment you must run
an experiment to prove whether the moon
is an object
isn't the moon an object before the
asteroid strikes it
isn't the table that the klingon has on
the other side of the universe an object
in spite of the fact that you can't see
or touch it
an object is not that which you can see
or touch not all objects can be seen
not all objects can be touched
an object is that which has shape
shape is a universal attribute
there is not a single object you can
imagine that doesn't have shape
and you must define the word object for
the purposes of physics because you
can't do physics without an object
[Music]
you